منذ حوالي عام ، كنت أتحدث إلى
طبيبي وقلت للتو أنني لا أستطيع التخلص من
هذا الاكتئاب ، يقول
إنني حصلت على وصفة طبية لك ، أوه ،
حبة أخرى يقول لا لا لا
لا أريدك  لقضاء ساعتين خلال
الأسبوع في
الهواء الطلق على
الأقل 20 دقيقة في كل مرة
، وكلما فعلت ذلك ، شعرت بشكل أفضل ،
لذا فقد
تضافرت جميعًا
بشكل أفضل من أي دواء سبق أن تناولته
الآن ، فأنت تعلم أنها تبلغ من العمر 75 عامًا ،
لذلك يجب أن أخبرك  أنت
تبلغ من العمر 91 عامًا. ولهذا السبب هي تعتني بي ،
أحاول أن أحاول أن أجرب
الطبيعة في كل مكان يمكننا أن نجدها
في أكثر الأماكن غير المتوقعة
والطبيعة هي
وصفة الحديقة الصحية أو الحدائق هي
برنامج وصفة الطبيعة الوطنية في كندا
ما هو الطبيب أو الطبيب  تقوم الممرضة
بالجلوس مع المريض
ومعرفة نوع الطبيعة القريبة
في مجتمعهم ومن ثم يعملون
معهم معًا للتوصل إلى
خطة حيث يمكنهم دمج
وقت الطبيعة في نمط حياتهم اليومية بعض
طماطم الكرز.
هو بريسكريب  وهي تعطي
اسمي وتقول إن خطة نشاطي في الهواء الطلق
في عام 2022 أعلنا عن تعاون جديد
مع متنزهات كندا حيث
يمكن للمهنيين الصحيين المرخصين الآن أن يصفوا
تصاريح اكتشاف وطنية تتيح لك الدخول إلى
المتنزهات الوطنية ، وهناك
برنامجان وطنيان فقط للوصفات الطبية في كندا.
يمكن أن يكون العالم والأول الذي تم
إنشاؤه في الواقع في الولايات المتحدة
عائقًا حيث توجد
رسوم استخدام يومية ، لذلك نأمل أنه من خلال
وصف هذه الحدائق ،
يمر اكتشاف المرشحين الذي سيقلل من
هذا الحاجز أمام الوصول إلى الطبيعة
بطريقة كبيرة
حسنًا ، هناك نظريتان رئيسيتان حول
سبب كون الطبيعة جيدة جدًا لأدمغتنا
، وتسمى الأولى
نظرية استعادة الانتباه عندما نقضي وقتًا في
بيئات حضرية مزدحمة ، كل الحواف الصعبة
وحركة المرور والإضاءة والناس في
كل مكان تجعلنا مضطرًا إلى
الاستمرار  نركز انتباهنا على نوع
من التنقل حول تلك العقبات
بينما عندما تقضي وقتًا في الطبيعة ،
فهذا هو المصدر حقًا  من الانبهار الناعم ،
لذا فإن ما يفعله ذلك هو أنه
يستعيد قدراتك على الانتباه
ويقلل من هذا التعب والتهيج ،
وتسمى النظرية الرئيسية الثانية
نظرية الحد من الإجهاد ، لذلك عندما
نقضي وقتًا في الطبيعة بعد الأحداث المجهدة ،
فإنها تساعدنا على أن نكون أكثر مرونة
والتعافي بشكل أسرع
عندما أوصيت بالطبيعة لأول
مرة لمريض من مرضي ، اعتقدت
أنه سينظر إلي بشكل مضحك
وسيضحك علي لكنه في الواقع
أومأ برأسه وقال إنك على
حق تمامًا عندما أقضي المزيد من الوقت
في الطبيعة  أشعر بتحسن ، لذا أعتقد أن على
مقدمي الرعاية الصحية أن يتغلبوا نوعًا ما
على التحيزات العقلية الخاصة بنا ضد
نوع جديد من تدخلات نمط الحياة وأن
يصفوا شيئًا قائمًا على الأدلة مثل
وقت الطبيعة في كثير من الأحيان
50 يومًا من البذور
إلى
الخضار وأعتقد أن الوصفة الطبية تساعد في ذلك
تقول أن هذا أمر جيد أن تفعل
هذا يستحق الجهد الذي يجب أن تفعله
تحتاجه للخروج من الأبواب وأن تكون
محاطًا بالمساحات الخضراء وبطبيعة الحال
أريد  ليعرف الناس أن الطبيعة يجب أن
تكون غير قابلة للتفاوض ، فإن الشيء الذي يتعلق
بالتوجه إلى الخارج هو أنك تميل إلى
البدء في أن تكون أكثر نشاطًا بشكل طبيعي
وستشعر بالهدوء وستشعر بالاكتئاب
أقل قلقًا وأعتقد أنها
طريقة رائعة للتعامل  مع ضغوط الحياة الحديثة
[موسيقى]